cool hello can anyone hear me all right
nice one uh thanks for bearing with me
very quick change over there so
um
welcome to my talk um i'm going to be
talking to you today about blazer and
tailwind css um these are two
technologies that i'm pretty enamored
with at the moment um
uh yeah i've talked a few times about
blazer
it's it's possibly the best technology
that's ever been invented ever
and the solution to all front-end
problems now i'm joking um
but yeah they're two technologies that
i'm very very sort of enamored with and
um there's also two technologies that we
use at the the company i work for so i'm
gonna talk to you about this as well
from the perspective of someone who's
actually doing this for real
and these two technologies um
are definitely very interesting things
um
just to quickly introduce myself so my
name is chris i'm a principal software
engineer at deployed we're a uk-based
startup
as i mentioned we're using blazer we're
using the whole.net stack and we also
use tailwind as well
i'm a microsoft mvp i have been for
about three years now
i do do some blogging at chrissani.com
but i've i've kind of not been doing
much of that for the last
two years 18 months two years because
i've been i've decided to write a book
because that's a that's always a fun
thing to do
and that's finally finished now so that
that's good um
and that's actually going to be going to
print in the next few weeks so so that's
nice to see that project come to an end
um and i also do some open source work
so i have a various packages under an
organization called blazid
um so there's local storage stuff in
there there's modals and toasts and what
have you to to help you build sort of
applications with blazer
a little bit easier
um so anyway enough about me let's get
into things so um we're going to start
with the basics here so we're going to
talk firstly a bit about what tailwind
is
and why it's different to other css
frameworks you may have used
and then we'll move over to visual
studio
and we'll do some uh we'll do some code
demos so
we'll actually look at how we can
integrate towerwind into a blazer
solution because tailwind's a little bit
different to to other css things
um and yeah we'll see how that works and
we'll see if we can build some
interesting stuff with blazer and
tailwind
so what is telling css well
tauwin css is what's known as a
utility-based css framework
so
what this means is that tailwind is full
of lots of atomic style classes okay
they're very small very very focused
usually they're focused on on a single
css property okay so you add a single
class to manipulate a single property
now
this is different to other frameworks
like bootstrap is probably the obvious
one to compare to because most of us
have probably probably used bootstrap at
some point
which i would i would class that as a
component-based css framework now what i
mean by that is when you go and use
something in bootstrap you usually go to
the docs and you go and get a card
component you copy the markup and the
classes and you get a card that looks
like it does in their docs
if you want an alert you go and copy
that markup with those classes you get
alert that looks like it does in their
docs same for buttons okay this kind of
leads to the scenario that happened
which is where every bootstrap site or
every site ended up looking like
bootstrap
and that is one of the issues with using
pre-built css frameworks that you end up
sort of using components relatively as
is and things sort of start to look the
same
that doesn't really happen with tailwind
because towing doesn't actually ship
with any pre-made components okay the
idea with tailwind is that we compose
these atomic classes together
in order to create a unique design
now if you're not particularly into
design this can sound a little bit
intimidating which is fair enough
but tailwind actually does have some
pre-made components available to you as
kind of a separate thing so there's some
free community options um and then the
actual tailwind people themselves have
another product called towel and ui
which is some paid for pre-made
components so you can invest in those if
you want to
but what i really like about towing css
is i i do like to do a little bit of
design work and it's nice to be able to
create something that's a little bit
more unique
the other thing that i tend to find when
i work with tailwind it's actually very
very quick to work with compared to
other frameworks now the reason for that
is that in tailwind you pretty much
never write css which is really
interesting sort of thought when you're
building front-end apps um
i've never been able to use bootstrap as
is i've always at some point ended up
having to write some custom classes you
have to manipulate things if you do want
to do something different to how
bootstrap has done it you are in a world
of either editing their base sas files
or you are going to be overriding their
classes or whatever
and that can be a real pain
i do not write like say very much custom
css for tailwind at all and in fact i'm
going to make a promise to you on this
stage right now that through the rest of
this talk you are not going to see me
write a single css property out inside
of any of the demos that i'm going to
show you later on um although we will
get a little bit close on that at one
point but it's technically true
cool
so let's have a look at an actual
example of this so
this is in fact the card component from
uh bootstrap's documentation site and
this is what i mean by a component so we
have an outer div with a a
class of card on it and then we have
various
uh chart elements after that that have
specific classes to do specific things
now this is a little bit customizable so
like if you say don't want the image you
just don't do the image with the image
card image top class on it and that's
fine you can add a button to this and
you can kind of play around the
structure a little bit but largely
you're kind of going to get what you
what you get
so we can actually replicate this in in
tailwind okay so this is what that same
component would look like if we wrote it
in tailwind so a little bit different a
few more classes but we're going to work
through them okay so
on that top outer div we're going to
start off by adding flex and flex coal
now this means that we're going to use
flexbox in order to
position everything and flex call is the
to do with the flex direction so what
this means is it's going to stack all of
the child elements up as a column okay
and then you can just see on hopefully
just about see on the screen there but
there's a shadow underneath that card
component and that's what shadow lg does
large shadow
moving on to the image we've got rounded
t now you probably can't quite see it
here but they're very very lightly
rounded corners on the top of that image
and rounded t rounds the top corners
h40 is to do with height height of 40.
now 40 isn't actually a pixel value or a
rem value it actually maps to a value in
a design system now that design system
is a really important point about
tailwind and we'll come back to that in
a minute
p4 is padding 4 again design system
we've got text gray 800 that's the text
color and the gray 800 again is to do
the design system we'll touch on that in
a sec
and then the h5 text lg large text font
semi bold mb margin bottom two
and then text base which is just a text
based size so
what i hope you can sort of gather from
this is that once you start to learn
what tailwind's naming convention is you
can basically read the styling
of any kind of elements in your markup
and this is where i feel that a lot of
the productivity comes to tailwind
because you don't change files if i'm
styling a piece of markup i only work
with that markup i just put those
classes in i'm not jumping around
between that and a css file writing out
custom classes going back over my html
applying it did that work okay you kind
of really speed up that loop
now i mentioned design systems tailwind
is basically one big design system okay
and this is a really big selling point
because
design systems are good they can strain
us because when you've got sort of any
and every option available to you
sometimes choosing something can be very
difficult you end up in analysis
paralysis
but tauwin's design system gives you
some constraint also means that you can
get some consistency okay
one of the things i tend to find with
bootstrap based sites is when you do
start writing these custom classes if
you have an app that gets big you tend
to find that the same things get
replicated
what you also find is the values don't
say consistent so you might agree on a
certain level of padding okay but then
someone does it at 14 pixels and then
someone does a class three months later
and that's 16 pixels and then you get
another one that's 12.
but it's in a ginormous css file that's
300 400 500 lines long and nobody's
scrolling up and down to to check that
consistency with a design system you can
kind of use that
constraint a lot more and because
everything's in the markup it's very
easy to find something to compare
against
the other nice thing is if you do have a
design team you can actually work with
them to codify your design language okay
and you can sit down with them you can
codify it into tailwind's configuration
and then you can be much more confident
that you're using the right color okay
or the right spacing or whatever
whatever it happens to be
this design system however does make
using tailwind slightly more complicated
than something like bootstrap okay so
with bootstrap you can just basically
take a css file you can add a link to it
in your in your html and you're good to
go you can just start writing out your
your your styles
that's not the case for taowin tailwind
has to be built
okay and the reason it has to be built
is because taiwan can generate
i think it's a 20 meg css file if every
single option is turned on
and this was the problem with tailwind
prior to version three which came out at
the end of last year
so what used to happen with towerwind
was that you had a set of sensible
defaults turned on okay and that would
generate a css file in dev that might be
around sort of three four five meg
something like that and you could
obviously turn on any other bits you
needed
and then when you wanted to actually go
to production you could do some stuff
called purging where you can pass in the
files that have towing classes in them
and tailwind's compiler would basically
look at what you use and it would strip
out everything that you don't use and
you get a smaller file
okay but that will change with tauwin v3
they move to a completely different
engine for doing this they move to
what they call the jit engine
now this is really cool because what it
means is every option is turned on by
default
what you do is when we configure tower
wind initially we have to pass in the
files that it should watch for the where
we're going to basically apply the the
utility classes to and every time we
apply one and save that file the jit
engine picks that up and it on the fly
recompiles the the css file to include
that new utility class so what it means
is when we're working in development
we're actually working with the same
file that we would get in production
okay so it's quite cool but it does mean
that we've got some extra steps
so in terms of what we can configure
there's color palettes in tailwind okay
so
this is an example of one they range
from different shades so we have 50
which is the lightest shade of any color
and 900 which is the darkest ships for
22 colors by default so it gives you a
pretty good starting point you can cut
as i said you can customize all this so
you can either override the existing
palette cancel it all out and just put
in the stuff that you want or you can
extend it
so once you've kind of configured this
up in the configuration file various
utility classes can then use colors so
using them looks like this so if i want
to say i want to color some text in a
certain way i just say text color and
whatever shade i want to use
same with background i'll just do bg
color and shade okay
spacing that's another thing
hopefully it's just about big enough
so this is what i was talking about the
mapping so on that first column on the
left hand side there that's the number
that you're going to reference in your
markup okay so that's that h40 that i
mentioned earlier and that then maps to
a a rem or a pixel value depending on
which particular one you're using
um
the nice thing about this as well is
like i said it's all centrally managed
so if you do ever decide that
40 shouldn't be uh i don't know whatever
it is by default it's about
five rem or six rem or something like
that you want it to be eight well you
can just change it in the design system
you don't have to go and change all your
markup because there's a bit of an
abstraction there so that's quite useful
and again this is how you'd use it so
this is you get various um utility
classes that can then access this this
spacing scale so padding width height
margins all those types of things
the other cool thing that tailwind has
in it is variants okay so what are
variants well variants are things like
pseudo classes so you would know them as
things like hover effects odd even
effects on rows
first last stuff like that you can do
all of that with tailwind okay so
again we can configure all the variants
that we'd want these are kind of there's
pretty much everything you want is
pretty much there out the box now with
with kind of v3 and the jit engine this
is a lot of the stuff that you used to
have to turn on but it's there by
default now which is quite cool
and they're just used like this if i
want to do a hover effect for example on
a button i can just say by default i
want my button to be red 500 but on
hover
i want it to be bg red 800 and go a
little darker okay that's all it takes
to do a hover effect
and i can even do dark mode stuff as
well so i can say well by default i want
my background to be white
except when i'm in dark mode and i want
it to be gray 800
all right
and like i said this is all configurable
so there's a tailwind config.js file
where you can set all this up you don't
need to do any of this because like i
said there's a lot of sensible defaults
there and um certainly where where i am
at deployed we've made very few changes
to the default settings
but this is kind of what you do so this
is an example of overriding the color
palette so
theme colors and then i've got various
colors here that i've put in if i wanted
to extend it i would have an outer
object
between theme and colors which would say
extend so that would extend what's there
with that new set of colors
so really what this uh could be
summarized as is that tailwind is
essentially just
lego blocks for ui design okay you just
compose them together to create the you
know the look that you want if you don't
like something you just swap one out for
another one okay
so
i'm just gonna
take a drink and we'll talk about this
in a second
now if you're
what's the word seasoned like i am and
you've been around for a little while
you'll know that there was a period
where inline styles were all the rage
and then we realized they were pretty
evil so we shouldn't do that anymore um
and this is usually a question that
people have when they're first
introduced to tailwind okay
this looks like inline styles chris then
they're evil what's what's what's the
crack
well let's talk about the limitations of
inline styles so firstly inline styles
are essentially just magic numbers magic
strings depending on what property
you're manipulating okay you're gonna
add a style tag to an element you're
gonna type in some properties and that
is it they're fixed on that element and
if you want it want those styles
somewhere else you're gonna copy and
paste them somewhere else and then if
you want to change them you're gonna go
to every place where they are and you're
going to manually change them right so
that's pretty rubbish
you can't do pseudo states either okay
so variants in tailwind right so no
hover effects or anything like that no
no odd and even you know color changes
on your tables or anything like that
that's not possible with inline styling
and the probably the biggest one in in
modern web development is you can't do
media queries so if you have any need of
responsive design which most people do
you can't do that with inline styles
either so so these three things are
pretty debilitating
if you're trying to build modern web
applications
but none of these are a problem in
tailwind because tailwind is still using
css classes okay they're just very very
focused
like i said at the start they're
basically focused on a single css
property and manipulating that one value
so let's
talk a little bit about how we actually
integrate this with blazer now
so the first option i'm going to talk to
you about is the quickest and the
simplest and that is uh integrating
using tailwind's new play cdn all right
so with the play cdn it's really really
simple we basically add a single script
tag
with that url
and then we just start writing our our
style classes
okay
we can just get going
now what's really nice here is um
all of the functionality you're gonna
get from local development still works
and this is what i think is really cool
about this cdn so it means all the
customization stuff that i mentioned
earlier you can still do that with the
play cdn all right you just open up a
script tag you create the tailwind
config object and you just write out
whatever custom configuration you want
as you would do with a tailwind
config.js file in local development and
it just works
so you can create
uh this is the extending of the color
palette palette
okay so i'm going to add this blazer
purple in and then i can just start
writing
classes that use that color and it just
works all right
plugins also work so tailwind has a rich
plug-in ecosystem there's various
plugins that are official and there's a
lot of third-party ones as well
the play cdn only supports the official
ones but they're
still quite useful
so in this case you just had a query
string with plugins and then you just
list out the names of the plugins that
you want to use
so this is really cool it's a really
good way to get familiar with tailwind
it's a great way to prototype it's a
great way to decide if it's for you and
your company or your project or whatever
the downside here is that it's not for
production use okay so the tailwind
guy's like no you can play around with
it you can try it out but it's not there
for production use so if you do want to
do production use if you want to build
this into a real project what are you
going to do well
we're going to go for option two here
and that's the tailwind cli
now
the tailwind cli historically has always
been uh
there through npm okay so this means
having node installed um using npm to
build stuff
now
i know that sometimes
when i talk to dot net people they can
be a little bit worried about node okay
and npm i get that i appreciate that
i've spent a lot of time in the front
end world it doesn't bother me but i
definitely understand why
however what i will say is that it's
still probably the best way to use
tailwind so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to compromise them and show you a
way of using it using the modern
versions or modern tools in npm okay
that means we're not going to have to
have a big node modules folder or
anything like that we're not going to
have a package.json file anything like
that at all okay
however
if you absolutely do not want to have
node in any way shape or form involved
in your in your
machine installations or whatever
then that's cool as well because if you
go to the releases page of tailwind's
github page they now do a standalone cli
this is standalone executable okay you
can download it for mac linux windows um
and you can just run that instead now
the reason i'm not going to use that and
i'm not overly keen is because you then
have to if you're using a ci pipeline
for example you then have to deal with
getting that in your pipeline and
executing it and whatever it just
becomes a bit of a pain whereas i think
the npm version is a lot simpler to do
cool so on that note let's uh let's
check out some code and see how we can
actually get tailwind integrated into
into a new project so
right where are we at here
cool
so this is a blazer web assembly project
okay um it's a little bit modified
because if you've sort of been following
blazer or anywhere near as much blazer
as i have you're probably getting quite
tired of the uh the standard template
okay that purple gradient starts to
starts to really
get to you after a while so what i've
done is i've reimagined it okay i've
i've
tried to redesign it make it look a
little bit more interesting so i put
very i've ripped out all of the
bootstrap stuff that ships with the
default template and i've applied a load
of utility classes already for styling
just because watching me do that it's
not gonna be overly interesting um but
what i've not done is set up towerwind
okay so we're gonna go through that
together and see what that looks like
so the first thing as i mentioned
earlier is that we do need a towel and
configuration file
so we're going to use
before i say that one set i have
installed node okay so that's the first
thing
i'm going to use a command called mpx
okay so it's slightly different to npm
if you've ever used that before the nice
thing about npx is it's not actually
going to download anything into a node
modules folder okay it works through
like a machine cache so i'm going to ask
it to execute certain packages and it's
going to store those in a central cache
on my machine if i've got it already
it'll execute it from there otherwise it
goes to npm and downloads it if i need
to but it doesn't put anything in my
actual project all right
so
i'll execute that first of all and
that's going to create me a tailwind um
configuration file so that's now at the
root of my project this is what the
default uh configuration file looks like
not got much in it which is it's cool um
the only thing we really have to do with
this is tell it where to look for the
files that contain the tailwind utility
classes okay and we do it in this
content array so
all we have to do here is add in the
path so
this is just going to say scan my
directory structure and just find any
files that end in razer or dot html okay
and that's where my tailwind classes
will be being applied
so that's the configuration file done
the next thing we need to do is create
an input css file okay because
tailwind's going to compile this into an
output css file so i'm going to add a
new folder
so we'll call that styles and we'll add
a new
a new style sheet to that
and then
i'm going to pop in these three lines so
these are directives okay um and
basically tailwind will take these and
it will convert them into the various
utility classes it needs to um it does
some other stuff as well so like in the
base stuff there is things like css
resets to make sure that everything is
even across browsers and stuff like that
but the actual workings of this you kind
of don't really need to care about at
this point okay
um so we've got that that's cool so now
we can go back to our command line
and we're going to run a different
command this time so i'm going to still
run mpx tailwind css so i'm going to
still execute the tower in cli but this
time i'm going to say
take this input file
so starsapp css
and then generate me an output file and
i want you to put that in the wwe root
folder css app css okay
now what i'm also going to do here is
i'm going to pass in a flag of minus
minus watch
so this is basically
tauwin's
jit or hot reload you can think of it
that way
so it's going to watch both that input
file so that styles app css and
anything that's in that path that we
passed into the content array okay and
it's going to watch for changes and then
regenerate
that output css file every time
something changes
so we'll get that going so that's
running and if we go into the wwe root
folder and we can see that file here
okay so this is that output generated
file
so you can see some classes that it's
already generated here
from what's already in the app
so the last thing to get this running is
not that
is to go into the host page and then i
just need to put in a link to that
output style sheet
all right
so that's it i've now got tailwind
integrated into my application so
let's run this and see what we get
cool so i'm just going to reset the zoom
on that a bit
so this is it this is the the new
template so it doesn't look overly
interesting at the moment and that's
because we do a bit more styling
together so we can see sort of some of
the basics of how tailwind works but it
certainly doesn't have a big purple
gradient down the left so that's that's
progress as far as i'm concerned
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to start off looking at the
headings so there's that very small
hello world welcome to your new app
so we're going to try and make this look
a bit more like uh or the hello world
bit might look more like a heading and
the welcome to your new app look more
like a paragraph so just going to do
some basic styling this time so
we're going to go to visual studio again
and we're going to open up that index
page
so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to add in some styles so i'm going to
say font extra bold
like so
and i need um i need that to be a lot
bigger so we'll say text
and we'll say 7xl because we want
something pretty big um and then i want
things to be a bit more spaced out
because you know space is always good so
we'll say tracking wide and that's just
going to put some space between the
letters to make everything fill out a
bit
and then finally we want a bit of a
margin at the bottom because you know
just to spread things out so i'm going
to do an mb6 okay
so we'll save that
go back over and hot reloads ruining my
life again
i just want to make this clear i have a
very very hate-hate relationship with
hot reloading in dot-net at the moment
as you can see
and it really does depend which way the
wind's blowing as to whether it actually
loads or not there we go anyway um so
that's it that's now a styled heading
okay so a few classes later
and i've got something that looks far
more like a heading okay so we can do
the same thing with the p tag as well
although that's going to be a little bit
more
more simplistic
um so i'm going to pop some bits in
there so we'll say text
text excel on that one
and uh this one wants a big margin
because of what i've done with it so
we'll put mb20 on that
cool so that's now slightly changed
we've got slightly bigger text now for
that paragraph and a big margin at the
bottom
okay so that's just some very simplistic
stuff and i'm just showing you that just
to give you a feel of what it's like to
do sort of what i would call day-to-day
styling all right throw some classes on
there when hot reload is actually
working that's a very quick process and
it kind of blips through very fast
so
let's do something a bit more
interesting
that panel over the there's a panel
there over over the right-hand side that
you won't be able to see very much at
the moment so it looks very bland but we
want to make this stand out a bit now
this is a good opportunity to do
something that i can never remember how
to do in css and i kind of consider
myself relatively decent at css but i
can never remember the syntax for doing
background gradients all right it's just
one of them things that i always end up
googling um so let's have a look how we
can do this in tailwind
so this is the markup
for that particular uh
piece of ui
so i've added three classes here
bg gradient 2br so that means it's going
to be a background gradient and it's
going to go to the bottom right it's
going to start in the top left so it's
going to go diagonal and it's going to
start with green 400 so from green 400
it's going to go to blue 500. all right
so we'll save that
and that's it i've now got a background
gradient all right
on my best day i cannot code that quick
enough in css i cannot get over to a css
file create a class google put that copy
and paste off stack overflow and get
back to my application okay
so this is one of the really cool things
i think about tailwind it makes this
stuff really trivial
let's look at another example of
something that can always be a bit
interesting is manipulating elements so
that means twisting them around moving
them about that kind of stuff so
this kind of unstyled text here is
actually
the the survey prompt that you get um in
the normal template so we want to make
this look a little bit more interesting
um first of all so let's open that up
i'm going to replace what's there
with some more interesting stuff
there we go so this now looks far more
like a banner that's helpful it's got a
again a bit of a background gradient
there we've got an icon and some colors
and it looks more interesting now but
what about if we want to skew this okay
so if i want to rotate it or i want to
flip it or i want to do anything like
that again
these are things that can be a little
bit more challenging when you're doing
it with with pure css
so let's try and rotate this a bit
right
there we go
two classes later
transform rotate
i want to transform this element and i
want to rotate it and i want to rotate
it by three now by default rotate is
going to move it clockwise
but i want to go counterclockwise so
i've got a minus at the front
all right
so
we'll do that we'll go back over
and now we've got a skewed element
okay so manipulating sort of elements
spatially is like say it's always one of
the things that's a bit more tricky but
two classes into our wind boom we're
there
so at this point i want to address
something that usually people are new to
towerwind uh start to think and that is
well that's cool chris but haven't i now
got a copy all of those classes you
apply to that h1 tag to every h1 in my
in my app and the same for my p tag and
what am i you know when i'm styling
common elements that are on every page
i've got to put this stuff everywhere
that doesn't sound much better than
inline styles right which is a fair
point
um the other thing is that um you
wouldn't have seen these checks having
it haven't showed you but this big panel
is actually on every page and again it's
got no styling on these other pages
because
i haven't copied those styles over so
that's a bit of a pain as well so we've
got two problems here
we've got elements that have repeated uh
markup that need to be common across our
app uh sorry styles that need to be
coming across our app and we have
repeated markup that needs to be common
across our app so we've got two problems
and i've got two solutions for you so
the first thing that we're going to look
at
is going to be dealing with
elements
um that are common across an app you
want to style central links you just
don't want to replicate this stuff
across all of your all of your various
pages
so to do this i'm going to open up that
input
style file okay
and i'm going to pop in a couple of
a couple of bits of code hold on there
we go
that one
and then for good measure we'll do the p
tag as well
so it's where i said i'm kind of
skirting close to what i said in my
promise earlier i have not written a css
property i've technically declared two
classes but i haven't written them
properly so i was right technically
right which is the best kind of right i
think
so
the apply directive is a really cool
feature of tailwind because what it does
is it allows us to use all the power of
that design system and all of the kind
of speed of those utility classes
okay but i still don't have to write css
properties all right i can get
reusability
so i can say now all my h1 tags apply
those
those utility classes and all my p tags
apply those utility classes
so we'll save that if we come back over
here i might need to reload this but
let's have a look
yep so we've got the class showing with
the various styles that we put on it
originally
so if we go back into the index.razer
we'll get rid of all that because we
don't need that now so we've got it
centrally styled
same on the p tag
save that
cool
so everything looks the same
we can now see in the browser tools
we've got no classes okay all centrally
styled nice get maintainability we can
change things easily
this is really useful for for headings
it's really useful for anchor tags it's
really useful for paragraphs okay
and it's a way of avoiding all that
repetition
so that's the answer to the first
problem
the second problem was repeated markup
okay so this is where we've got this
panel that's replicated across all the
various pages okay
so how do we deal with that
well this is where blazer comes in right
so blazer is a component-based framework
like most other front-end frameworks and
this is a perfect example of where
components are useful so what i can do
is i can create a new component here so
i'll add one in
we'll call this tailwind
and then inside of here
we'll put in the same markup that we've
got replicated across the various pages
right so once we've got that i can save
that component i'll get rid of these
other files because you don't really
need these anymore
and then i can just replace what i've
got here
with that component
so i'll do it on
i'll do it on the index page we can do
it here on the counter page as well
and also do the same on the fetch data
page so let's scroll down we'll get that
cool
so there we go so we've now got the same
component being displayed across all
three pages we've got all that
duplicated markup now in one place and
we can restart this however we want okay
so those are the two solutions to those
two problems
and they're pretty cool i think there's
a nice simple way of dealing with those
so everything i've been showing you up
till now has been
relatively rudimentary i think okay so
you're probably like okay i can't do
something a little bit more cool
fair point so let's talk about
animations all right
so animations uh usually involve things
like javascript and they can be a bit
fiddly and like how do you actually go
about doing them and getting them time
right and whatever um
agreed so what i thought we'd do is we
will build a component that allows uh we
can wrap mark up and make it slide
around right that'll be a cool thing to
do
um so let's start that so what we're
gonna do is this big panel on the on
that we've got over there on the right
hand side we're going to make that slide
in okay because it'll just make the page
a little bit more interesting when it
first loads
and it's a good demo
so we're going to start off with adding
a new component
and i'm going to call this imaginatively
the slide in component
and then let's put in some markup
so there's a few things going on here so
let me highlight the important stuff to
you first of all we're going to be using
a timer a net timer all right none of
this is going to involve javascript
there's no javascript interrupt going on
whatsoever here
um
and this is what's known in blazer as a
template component okay so what this
means is i'm going to wrap some content
and i'm going to want to capture the
content i'm rendering so i can put it
somewhere in this component's output and
i can manipulate it and in blazer we do
this by declaring a component parameter
with the name of child content and a
type of render fragment that's a
convention
and then what happens is when i wrap it
i can then output
whatever's wrapped wherever that where
on line five where i'm outputting child
content all right so that's going to
basically output inside of that div
okay
now we need to style this div with some
bass
uh stuff so
first of all i'm saying h full so i want
this to be the height of whatever it's
in all right so take maximum height
that's not overly interesting the next
ones are the ones that are fun so
transition duration 500. so
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to manipulate two css properties
okay we're going to change them from one
value to another
now with transition when you do that you
can transition those values check those
value changes over a period of time and
that's what duration 500 is going to say
change those values over a duration of
500 milliseconds and this is what's
going to help us create an animation
effect
we've got transform on there as well
because i'm going to want to move this
element around okay what i'm going to
want to do is slide it off the screen
when i when it first renders so i can
slide it back on all right so that's why
transform's there
and then i'm outputting the value of a
private field here called animation
styles all right so we haven't got
anything in that at the moment so
we need to put some stuff in there to
get this going so
um the first thing we're going to want
in here
are the two uh classes that we're going
to start with so translate x full okay
is going to move whatever we wrap 100 of
its width to the right okay so if we
jump back onto our
site it's going to push that off the
screen okay
to the right hand side
and then i'm setting opacity to zero now
this doesn't mean it removes it from the
dom structure it's still going to take
up the physical space it just makes it
transparent
okay so it's going to start all the way
to the right and transparent
so
what we now need to do is fill in a few
of the gaps so first of all
i need to set up my timer so i'm going
to set this timer up in uninitialized
okay it's a life cycle method on blazer
components it only runs once you can
think of it a bit like a constructor
and in there i'm going to set my timer
to 300 milliseconds
and then i'm going to say when it
elapses
call this method trigger animation
all right
now we haven't added that so let's add
that now
so trigger animation is kind of the
thing that does the cool stuff so what
it's going to do is it's going to update
animation styles and it's going to
overwrite what's there by default and
it's going to change it to translate x0
and opacity 100.
and this is the bit that is kind of
going to make all this hang together
okay because with transition
we're still manipulating the same css
properties okay under the hood
so what it's going to do translate x0 is
going to move it back to where it was
first rendered before we push it off to
the right and opacity 100 is going to
make it visible again okay but it's
going to happen over 500 milliseconds
and that's the key point that's what
will create the animation effect
so the last thing we need to do here is
actually trigger that animation effect
so we're going to do that using on after
render which is another life cycle
method in blazer and we're going to make
sure we only do this once because we
don't want to get like motion sickness
with this thing flying in left right
constantly that's going to be bad so
we're going to start the timer on the
first render and that's it and i've also
set it to auto reset false
so that's our sliding component done if
we come back over to our
towering component we're just going to
wrap that
like so so let's save that
and let that reload and we've got a
sliding component so
that wasn't too bad i've not used any
javascript or anything like that i've
just combined c sharp and tailwind in
order to create this effect now it's
almost
sort of um
although it's not doing it oh yeah it's
on the screen hold on wait
okay
windows 11's toolbars being joined so if
that toolbar was out of the way you'd
see that actually what's happening at
the moment is when i swap between pages
it's actually putting a horizontal
scroll bar there okay and that's the
browser trying to be helpful because
it's going oh there's something over the
right hand side out of the viewport you
probably want to see that i'll get you a
scroll bar but obviously we don't in
this case so um we can make a little fix
for this so in my uh index page the host
page
um i can just add overflow x hidden okay
to the body tag and that just means
anything that's not in the viewport it's
not going to create a horizontal scroll
bar for all right so that just fixes
that problem although
my lack of the the toolbar hiding is is
kind of ruining the effect of that but
take my word for it um so anyway
that is how we can do simple animation
effects okay um with using blazer and
tailwind together now this is obviously
a very simplistic example
but hopefully you can see how you can
extrapolate upon this and create
something a bit more interesting a bit
more reusable you could define other
parameters the set which direction it
was going to come in from you could have
a parameter to change the duration so it
did over a longer or short period of
time and stuff like that this just kind
of gives you an idea of what's possible
so
next thing dark mode
a must have for every modern website app
or anything
so dark mode is something i'm a big fan
of
um and um
this is not dark mode this is very very
light
so let's fix that okay let's make this
into oh let's have this site have a dark
mode option
um
this is actually going to be relatively
painless so i'm going to come back over
to visual studio here open up the
tailwind config and i'm just going to
add in
an extra bit of uh configuration here so
uh let me find my snippet
oh that's not it
that's not it
that's it so
dark mode i'm going to set oh actually
no i'm not going to sorry i'm jumping
ahead of myself
i don't even need to do that
i'm just going to come in with browser
settings
and i'm gonna set to my system default
which is dart mode and i've got dart
mode
that's too simple even for me for a
minute there and i wrote this talk um
so the reason for that is that as i
mentioned at the start we're telling v3
in the jit mode
every variant is turned on by default
and dart mode is a variant okay like i
showed you earlier you can just put dark
colon in front of any class and it will
get applied when dart mode's active
now by default
dart mode is turned on based on system
preference or browser preference
whichever one you you have to be using
um now i've already styled this with
dark mode classes okay so that's why
this has happened i i'd love that that
wouldn't be sensible enough to somehow
generate magically at a dark mode site
but unfortunately
i did actually have to do this so i
haven't uh started the title bar there
so
let's quickly just go through that just
so i can show you exactly what what goes
on um so you can see the outer
class here we've got bg white
and then on the links um they've got a
certain color of purple and stuff like
that so we basically can just replace
that
uh with some slightly different markup
and there you go bg white but now you're
saying when it's dark mode do grade 700.
all right that's that's what you that's
how you you get these dark mode
alternatives
um
so if we do that let that reload and now
we've got dark mode header all right so
that's how you apply those classes by
saying watching me do that is not going
to be interesting um so that's cool but
the kind of downside about this is that
you are kind of stuck with this based on
system preference having to go into your
browser sort of settings and toggle
between light and dark mode is a little
bit of extra work that we don't want to
necessarily have to do
so it would be much nicer if the user
could just decide if they want light or
dark mode with the toggle so let's build
a toggle component in order to
make this a bit more friendly for user
choice
now
to do this this time around we do have
to go to taiwan's config file and we do
have to add in
dark mode class
so
we do this because like i said by
default it'll work off your system
preference but when you set dart mode to
class what this means is that there
needs to be a class called dark
somewhere in your html structure and any
elements that are chart elements of that
will then have their dark variants
applied all right
so now i've applied that you can see
that the cli has kicked in it's done a
reload and now i'm not getting any dart
mode stuff applied all right because
it's not got that class anywhere so if i
open up my browser tools
and let's just come up here to the top
and where i've got this h full if i add
a dark class
like that
then it goes
everything goes back into dark mode
right
and that is basically what we need to do
with our component we need to write a
component that is going to toggle that
class on and off okay when someone
interacts with with our with our toggler
so let's go and have a look at that
so first things first let's add a new
component
call it dark mode toggle
and then we'll pop in
the initial markup okay
so um
i'm injecting some stuff at the top
there um the key one at the moment that
i'll point out is the igs runtime
unfortunately this time around i am
going to have to use some javascript
there's nothing i can actually do about
this i just can't manipulate that html
element from blazer it doesn't have any
sight or control of that so i'm going to
do that with with some javascript
um
the local storage thing we'll talk about
in a minute after that we've got the div
which is actually the thing that's going
to render our little toggle switch so
there's a lot of markup here that's
going on but the key thing um that makes
this work
is that we're using a trick here so
we've got a label with a four tag and
we've got a hidden input okay that's
attached to that label so the label is
gonna be the thing we click that's gonna
look like a slider but it's actually
just going to pass that click onto that
hidden input
so that's a check box and over here
we're handling that event so the
whether
whether that
is toggled on or off is going to be
based on whether this dark mode property
we've got is true or false so the
checked
attribute is set based on that value
and then whenever that
checkbox value changes we're going to
call this
toggle theme method okay and that's
going to be the thing that's going to do
the work to actually add or remove that
that class
cool so if we just save that for now and
let's actually just quickly have a look
what this looks like so we'll add this
into the markup
cool so
up there top right hand side you can
just see there's a little toggle going
on
so it starts to look like a toggle and
everything and we're going to click that
and it's going to swap back and forth
based on whatever whatever preferences
we have
so let's actually do something to make
this work so
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to get the javascript bit out of
the way so
i'm going to add a new file here
come down find javascript and i'm going
to use a new feature in dot net 6 which
is called co-located javascript so this
is pretty neat so i can say
dark mode toggle which is the name of my
component dot razer dot js
and then visual studio is going to very
nicely nest it for me over there and
what's cool about this is i get to keep
my javascript with the component that's
using it right this is a pretty cool
feature and then tied in with
the support that blazer has for js
modules um i don't actually have to put
a reference to this js file anywhere in
my application blaze is just going to
load it for me dynamically whenever i
actually try to import the module all
right
so
let's put in the initial markup so i'm
going to export a single function out of
this module it's called set theme it
takes a theme as a string if it's dark
it adds that dark class to the html
element or if it's not it removes it
okay very simple that's it that's all
the javascript we're doing
so we'll get rid of that now
so we now need to import that module
into this component so we can actually
call that method when we need to
so let's add in some code to do that
so
first thing i've got a private field
here i js object reference as its type
that's how we store
references to javascript objects in
blazer
and then i've got on after render async
this is where you should always do all
your javascript interop
and inside of there i'm using the js
runtime
and i'm calling in vocatesync and then
i'm calling a special a special
function called import okay
and then the second argument i'm passing
here is basically the the path to that
particular file right so that's gonna
import that file into my app so i can
use it inside of this component
now being a responsible programmer i'm
also going to
implement my async disposable because
when i'm doing anything with javascript
object references i need to make sure i
dispose of them properly so i don't get
memory leaks
so we'll do that now quickly um so we're
gonna say if the theme module isn't null
then we'll we'll dispose of that so
that's the responsible programmer bit
done
um and then i'm gonna update this toggle
theme method
so this code is kind of quite
straightforward really um what we're
going to do is we get the value from
whatever the checkbox value is okay and
then we're going to set the dart mode
property field based on that
um if we're in dark mode um it'll be
it's going to pass down the string dark
otherwise it's going to pass down light
and then we're just calling that set
theme function with whatever the value
is all right
so now that's done
we've now got a working toggle all right
so we can click on that and that's going
to switch us between light and dark mode
and that's all it's doing is adding and
removing that dart class on that on that
html element so that's pretty cool um
the only downside here is that if i set
it to dark mode and i refresh the page
it goes back to light mode and that's
because there's no mechanism here for it
to remember what my settings are so
that's a bit rubbish because i'd have to
toggle this on all the time so we can
make a slight improvement here so this
is where that
ilocal storage service comes in this is
a shameless plug for blazered local
storage one of my packages um so this
allows you to interrupt with the local
storage apis okay using pure c-sharp you
don't have to do any javascript stuff so
install the nuget package register the
service and inject it in and you can
just start interacting with local
storage
so
what we can do is we can just in the
toggle theme method after we set the
theme um we can then just call local
storage and we can set a new key called
theme with whatever the value is okay
and that'll just persist that into local
storage for us so we can then uh go and
get that next time
so that's what we'll do finally in this
on after render we'll go up here and
we'll actually add in the code
to go and get that out so on the first
render of this component we're going to
go into local storage
in
i'm going to look for a key called theme
we're going to get the value out and
then we're going to set dart mode based
on that value and then finally we're
going to call set theme so we set it
initially to whatever
the you know the save value was okay
so if i come into my app now and i set
to dart mode and i refresh it stays in
dark mode okay
so if i come over here to my app you can
see that i've got this theme
key with a value of dark and that's
where it's pulling it from so as i
toggle that you can see that value
change
as i go
so that's pretty cool we're now to
create a nice toggle component we've
been able to store the values so we
don't have to toggle it back and forth
each time so that's pretty successful
i'm i'm quite happy with what we've got
here in this site
so
the final thing i'm going to talk about
is how do you actually go to production
with this all right how do you integrate
this into a ci build or whatever
well you've got a couple of options um
if you're going to go
uh the npm route and i've been i've been
showing you you could just add a new
step into your build pipeline okay so
you could install node you could run
uh
npm
and you could
run that same command i showed you in
your pipeline and then you can go on to
the step that actually builds your
project so that's one way of doing it
but there's also another way you can do
it which i'll show you here quick which
is that you can do this using ms build
so inside of the cs proj file
i'm going to add a couple of targets
here
so the first one this top one here
has kind of a bit of a safety check that
all that's going to do is run the npm
minus v command to make sure that node's
installed so if that isn't if node isn't
there it's going to fail the build all
right and that's because otherwise you
won't get an output css file
the more interesting one is the next one
okay so this this build css target
so
this is going to run before the compile
step so this is going to run before the
app gets built um and what it's going to
do is it's going to run that same mpx
command that we were running from the
command line and it uses the same input
so we have the input of the
the
input style file and then we have the
output style file the difference here
though is at the end instead of using
minus minus watch i'm using minus minus
minify and that's because obviously i
don't need to watch this file i'm not
doing more development in my pipeline um
but i do want to minify it okay and the
cool thing about the cli is it comes
with minifying built in and that's
because under the hood it it's actually
using post css okay so towing is a
actually a post css plugin which means a
lot of other post css plugins are
available to you and minifies one of
them and they've bundled that into the
cli so you don't have to do extra stuff
um as a bit of a sanity check as well
i have put a condition on this to say
that only uh execute this target if
we're in a release build all right so
when i'm doing local dev this isn't
going to accidentally be be going off
so if we put that in place we can
hopefully see this working so um
if i go over to my terminal i'll cancel
that watch that we had before
if i change over to release mode now and
build
and then we'll go have a look at that
output css file and there you go
we now have a minified
version of our css file all right
minified and as small as it could
possibly be
um
nice one um so
on that note
what we got time wise uh
that's my book if anyone's interested
i'll just get this out the way there is
a discount code if you do want to buy it
um and stuff but otherwise
the slides in the code you can get that
url
thank you for watching if you have any
questions i think we've got a minute or
two um but yeah otherwise thank you very
much enjoy the rest of the day
[Applause]